ride through the city like BR I'm on a
mission to get it ride through the city
like
BR and now
Brandon six
sh yeah what is popping fam it's
November 13th it's a Monday Monday
Monday 9:00 a.m. it's 9:03 a.m. okay we
start three minutes late guys we take a
warm hand to chin and casy's face
whatever dude we just have to go over a
bunch of stuff what's going on guys uh
hope you had a nice weekend chin you're
fishing killing murdering fish is that
did I see that on the on the the Graham
as the kids call it yeah but I didn't
murder anyone or I didn't Mur oh the
fish got away no fish yes one bite but
no fish yes yes when I hear you don't
murder fish I go yes case I saw where
were you golfing yes sir all you do is
golf dude that's it that's all I want to
do that's all I care about you're sh the
golf and you played with your brother no
I played with my buddy Mark oh wow you
guys look similar though right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I thought it was
your brother whatever uh that's cool man
good killing fish in golf balls uh I
went to uh Phoenix Arizona flew there
with my kiddo LT gay me and him flew out
on Friday
morning um cuz your boy was trying to
find a diamond in the rough um for this
Toontown show which debuts tomorrow
right 9:00 a.m. yes that's the plan
case yeah yeah yeah yeah it's been a
beast in this thing together but the
first episode drops tomorrow at 9:00
a.m. on the Toontown YouTube uh it's all
uh Automotive mainly trucks in some cars
on there first uh few episodes are my
TRX the sandblast TRX converting it to a
TRX demon basically so the goal was a
th000 horsepower realize that was pretty
easy to get to so uh it's going way
beyonder than the thousand horsepower we
got a lot of cool stuff coming up uh but
you just can't stop there you know you
can't just do a a show based off uh a
TRX so then I always wanted a uh a
lightning a generation to lightning as a
as a young man in high school if you had
this dude I figured your Wier was made
out of gold and you were basically the
Elon Musk of 2023 I just thought you
were the richest man in the world this
car back in 2004 2003 it started
generation 2 started in
1999 I got very famous by Paul Walker it
has a cult following but um that car in
2004 is probably 36 grand out the door
so you weren't exactly balling like I
thought as a kid as a young man when I
say kid I mean I'm 16 17 18 years old um
but so
I was struggling whether to get a
generation 2 or gener generation one
lightning Ford Lightning uh the
generation one started in 1993 to
1995 we found one it looked dope online
it checked out everything looked all
good I'm like that's the move and then I
have a inspectors who will go you know
make sure that it it checks out um
before I fly down there to pick it up
and drive it back cuz that's what I like
to do and they call me
with this thing a disaster it's all
rusted out uh nobody should buy this car
so then my heart was broken and then uh
we stumbled upon this 2004 generation 2
Lightning which still make it fun plan
was generation one but generation 2 is
going to be fun we had some big plans
for it uh sourcing a Godzilla engine now
a Ford Godzilla engine a bigger uh
blower on it would do the suspension I
have my vision for as as far as the
Cosmetics of the of the lightning so
that's the next project man but when you
have two projects going on at the same
time it's a lot not going to lie to you
guys it is a lot but uh passion of mine
so might as well you know shoot it and
see if you guys dig it but uh I would do
this whether there's cameras or not so
let's see how it goes but the the the
first episode the debut episode is
tomorrow 9:00 a.m. and that's on uh
Toontown YouTube man uh the drive back
from Arizona pretty easy my son loves
nothing more on this planet than hotels
So the plan was it's about a 7h hour
drive from Phoenix to LA plan was just
go all through the night but uh he
wanted to stay in a hotel so we stopped
in Palm Springs stopped in Palm
Springs Downtown Palm Springs it's a
little hoodie I didn't know this there's
parts of it that get a little rough out
there and this hotel I just we pulled up
to it uh it was interesting it was
interesting had the best steak of my
life in Palm Springs I think it's called
J bees Steakhouse best steak I've ever
had best steak I've ever
had is it JB's Palm Springs let's
see JW LG's oh LG's LG's best steak I've
ever
had I've had Steak All I've had meat in
my mouth all over this country and
international I've had meat all in my
mouth and there has not been a better
filet uh or prime rib that has touched
these sweet sweet lips that you guys
think are
fake uh than that Steakhouse in Palm
Spring rings but I'll tell you what man
that steak doesn't come free it doesn't
come free and neither does buying
pay-per-views or just life in general so
that's why you need to partner up with
my friends at DraftKings it's called a
smooth transition fellas that's right
DraftKings they got you covered with the
NBA NFL's popping right now you got UFC
of course which I was right two for two
on the co-main event main event which
we'll get into um but DraftKings sports
book has your back this week new
customers can score 15 instantly in
bonus bets just betting five bucks on
the NBA win or lose you get an instant
dub download the draft King Sportsbook
app now use the code shop show new
customers can get
150 instantly in bonus bets for betting
just $5 ruse on basketball or NFL or UFC
we got you man the crown is yours I
gotta read this don't I chin yeah unless
you want case or I to read it won't you
do it dude let me see let me see what
your reading like case who wants to do
it it all you CH I'm doing
something all right um where'd you stop
at uh gambling
problem you just want me to do it dude
go for it dude staying way too long I
thought it' be smooth Jesus Christ
gambling problem call when Gambler New
York call 8778 Hope NY or text heny 467
369 West Virginia visit ww. 1800
gambler. net please play responsibly in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8887895118
show shout out to
DraftKings oh boy yeah Phoenix was lit
uh when I say lit I was there for about
3 hours and then we drove back stayed in
Palm Springs my son had a scrimmage for
his travel ball team at 8: a.m so we
left at 4:00 a.m. um I tell you what the
lightning in 2004 especially 1999 2004
was considered a fast car 0 to6 m
57 you can get toy Camry that fast from
Toyota these days so the fast is all
relative at of the time um it came stock
with 380 horsepower 450 PBS of torque
it's a light
vehicle the guy before me was the guy
from
um I want I I keep saying Duck Dynasty
but it's not what uh uh Not To Catch a
Predator um what what's the other catch
uh Deadliest Catch oh The Deadliest
Catch the old man from Deadliest Catch
had this lightning he had some issues
getting in and out of the car he had
some back issues so he sold the car so
it's a 2004 20-year old car with only
22,000 miles so he gave it up because he
couldn't get in and out of the thing and
then your boy stumbled upon it so we had
some plans for it
but it it's a dope car it's it it's not
as fast that my TRX is absolutely blow
the doors off of it right now
um but it was faster 2004 compared to
cars now and so that's the goal is to
get it as fast as cars now and even
faster so that's the plan man but it's
interesting driving a car from 2004 it's
it's it's different it's just different
it's not all about 0 to 60 it's just
different um but let's get into the
fights man we had a great great uh UFC
pay-per-view over the weekend in Mass
Square Garden the influence mad Square
Garden in New York City uh down there
this card did not disappoint one of the
best main cards from the first fight
with Diego Lopez to the last fight with
Alex Piera one of the best top to bottom
main cards I've ever seen all of them
were fantastic fantastic the whole card
was just great F fantastic for a
pay-per-view UFC 295 delivered an every
facet possible for the people who were
who bought tickets to this UFC 295 and
were banking on Jon Jones and St Bay
offly that fell off the ticket prices
were like the highest we've ever seen in
the UFC so I bet they were pretty
disappointed that they paid all that
money the good thing is even if you're a
casual there's no way you could be
disappointed in the product that you
paid for this card is one of the best
we've had in a long hot second again
from top to bottom on the main on the
main pay-per-view that you paid for you
got all finishes and they were not not
like sleeper fights in any facet they
were great um my pick for DraftKings as
far as underdogs now if the money's even
I'm not picking these guys this is my
pick so you can make money hopefully
they are Underdog for a reason it was
Jared Gordon Mark Matson Mark Matson was
having success early on and then got
starched by Jared Gordon I'm a Jarry
Gordon fan uh you know if I wasn't
betting with my mind on that one as far
as picking a dog on the entire card
Jared Gordon would be my pick but uh he
looked
fantastic um but to kick off the the
main card Diego Lopez good God that Pat
sabatini got
absolutely destroyed Diego
Lopez uh First Team all Hot Topic with
his here he looks like he should come
out to some 41 you know he come out to
you know there's a p Ocean Avenue but he
does doesn't lean into that he doesn't
lean to the Hot Topic Vibe he should he
should come out to some 41 some First
Team all boner this kid is a dime piece
has great here checks the box as far as
Brazilian and Mexico he trains out of
Mexico so um he's going to be a forced
to be reckoned with man he looked fan
freas there's a couple guys it's tough
to give somebody MVP on this main card
because Diego Lopez could be a candidate
for it and then the freaking First Team
all God of War Ben was
Denise uh steamrolled our boy Matt
steamroll up for Rola that was a bummer
it's a bummer I text Matt after uh when
I was dealing with losses I always lik
when people said I feel sorry for the
next guy it's just you got to move on
you know and you're going to get
motivation there um that was a tough one
that was a tough Matt's been this dog
for his last you know he has his
three-fight win streak three Knockouts
and they keep giving these tough tough
fights um I don't get it he checks all
the boxes he has a personality he's a
former veteran you know he's uh he just
checks all the boxes man people love
this guy and they just keep throwing the
freaking wolves uh and this is where you
know they absolutely threw him to the
complete wolves with this French
Wolverine who's a special forces dude it
was a tough one yeah it was a super
tough one that kick straight to the face
um on the exchanger of him trying to get
out of there that head kick was tough
man now Beno called out um gaii and then
he called out uh Dustin porier I'm a fan
but chill out right you're not gonna
jump the queue you're not gonna go from
being on rank to fighting Justin gatei
and Dustin por that's not how this thing
works typically there there's some guys
that they'll do that with but
lightweights pretty stacked so for him
let me see the rankings at lightweight
he's sure as hell not getting any of the
people they called out awful call outs
by the way they show Justin engaging the
crowd he's like wait what who so it's
just if you you got to make sure if
you're going to do a call out it has to
make sense you might as well call out
Stipe it it's just not going to happen
so the top seven you can forget
about RDA at 10 would be a fun
one Drew Dober doesn't make sense cuz
he'll be ranked I I would assume he
jumps the queue and he he's ranked 14 so
Matt's going to fall out
Denise to jump into 14 Drew Dober just
lost to Matt so that does Drew Dober
fight doesn't make
sense
uh Rd at 10 I
dig Jaylen Turner could be interesting
and then you also got Dan hooker and
Bobby green fighting that Austin card
the winner of that to get him into the
uh higher up into the top 10 especially
if Dan hooker were to win you do Dan
hooker versus uh Denise that'd be fun
yeah or RDA but as far as him calling
out gamrot and porier and gatei you
might as well shooting his shot though
you shoot your shot you might as well
call out Michael
Jackson what are we doing use your use
your call out wisely man you know might
as well call out Jon Jones Tay's going
wait what it's a complete waste of time
complete waste of time that that fight
as as cool it was to see a finish it
just sucks for my boy Matt yeah but
Matt's the man head up buddy um that's a
tough one I don't know a lot of guys are
gonna sign up to fight benois it it
that guy God of War fits him
perfectly that guy is such a Savage um
moving on Jess gandra McKenzie
der so you have the number five fighter
in the world Jess gandra falling on
tough times um going through a divorce
she's talked about that pretty openly
and then McKenzie dur what was seven I
think rankings
yes almost pop 37 um what is is
she hold
up she's straw right uh she's seven
there you go yeah she's seven Jessica's
five Booyah memory CT my ass
um this fight's tough I'm a huge
McKenzie D fan I love McKenzie
der oh how do we want to put this where
we're not mean about it the the
level of skill going from
Ben W Matt fola Diego Lopez um you know
especially when you get to the co-main
event Main Event Tom Aspen Sergey
pavlovic Alex Pier Yi uh and
yui the level of skill from the number
five and seven female fighters to the
level of even on rank guys is so drastic
it's so such a big gap and women's
division is a lot newer so there's going
to be that kind of difference the issue
with MacKenzie Duran is she's the most
dangerous girl in the world on the
ground but at this level especially in
2023 if you
can't force a takedown if you don't have
the skills to take anybody down and use
your Jiu-Jitsu you're pretty screwed in
2023 her wrestling is nowhere where it
needs to be to compete at the top five
level and then her striking she so she
she can't take these other opponents
down so then she's forced to strike
she's been striking
for 4
years 5 years Max and then you're going
to rely on your striking to beat these
world
class Fighters it's just it's a recipe
for
disaster it's very similar what happened
to Rhonda when she was coming to the top
her grappling and Judo was so much
higher than everybody else she didn't
have to rely on her striking and then
you get to a level where you run into
this wall and you run run into a girl
who can defend the takedown or defend
those judo throws or defend those
Jiu-Jitsu trips and takedowns and stuff
and you're forced to strike but you
don't have the experience there's not
enough hours in the day there's not
enough years to catch up as far as
technique and to be comfortable on the
feet to even survive and then things get
real and it go south very very fast and
that's what's going on with Mackenzie D
it does not get better for her it just
does there's
there's nothing she can do to make up
that Gap in Striking there's absolutely
nothing she can
do if on her team you know and she's
left Jason pillo which is insane yeah
that she her striking was actually good
with pillo like better all relative
better all relative better for sure but
you see the holes in her game when it
comes to the de when when you sign up
for striking everybody wants to work on
offense the way you become world
champion is that your defense you you
look at all the world champions whether
it's male or female they're the best
with their
defense look at all the Champions look
at Strickland is Strickland the best
because he has the hardest punches the
best combos nope he doesn't get hit Tom
Asal doesn't get hit isy coming up
doesn't get hit you know vinoski doesn't
get hit you look at all the all the
Champions shevchenko when she was
Champion grao when she they don't get
hit their defense is what gets them to
the party so it's fun especially when
you don't have a background it to work
on your offense the issue with that is
the defense especially when the bullets
are flying live so for McKenzie Duran
You Can Tell She's just uncomfortable in
the exchanges her you know her Chin's up
she's winging it and then you fight
these girls who sit in the pocket man
and it's just it's going to get tough
for her it's going to get tough for her
the chances of being Champion are not
good it's just not good and this happens
when someone has a extensive grappling
base and they can't imply their will
they can't get an opponent down they're
forced to strike you're screwed you're
screwed and and she's 30 there's just
and she's one of my faves I absolutely
love McKenzie Duran she has she checks
every box to be a complete Superstar
looks good speaks well great person
phenomenal Jiu-Jitsu checks every
box except for the skill set when it
comes to striking and wrestling if I'm
her team dude send her ass to dagistan
or AKA she should be wrestling 247 she
doesn't need to do Jitsu ever again just
keep wrestling you're not going to
become Champion striking that's never
happening that's none the cards take
your ass to dagistan sleep on a wooden
bench hang out with the goats go up the
freaking Mountain like khabib and Mev
did and just Embrace that wrestling and
take take every single opponent
down there's tatana Suarez hey man what
can we do you know but as far as
striking it's just it's not for her
there's not enough hours in the day
there's not that was tough to see tough
to watch tough to
watch uh the co-main event Main Event
your boy called it took Tom ASP under
five I thought he'd get the submission
didn't think You' get a knockout in
freaking a minute which is insane uh and
then Alex and yer predicted Alex be a
knockout is a TKO we'll talk about that
early stoppage maybe I think chin likes
to see people die um so that's fine but
Tom Asma what's interesting about this
is Tom fought the the scariest dude in
the division Sergey
palovich and he did a interview with uh
uh senko and in this interview he
revealed that he had a back injury and
didn't
train over a week before the
fight so the fight was on a two week
notice so he trained exactly sevenish
days maybe less than that and became
world champion and not only did he beat
Sergey he beat him at his own game he
knocked him out in un or basically in
under a minute 30 in under 90 seconds
mindblowing on a two-e notice you know
bisbing was the first to do this again
on a two-e notice when he became world
champion the first English Champion now
Tom asol carries that Throne Tom asol is
hands down your world heavyweight
champion
Undisputed here's the issue and this
goes to the light heavyweight and
heavyweight division the issue is
there's no path forward next everything
is jammed everything's in this weird
kind of clogged division so at
heavyweight you have steepe and Jon
Jones that was supposed to be for the
regular heavyweight title Jon Jones
blows his peack out he's out at at least
a year then Stipe and John need to fight
in order for Tom to become the absolute
Champion I disagree with this I
think Stipe and John we're going to tune
into whatever it it doesn't we don't
need a belt for that fight that's a
legacy fight and John being out so long
I think you got to give Tom and I think
they're going to do this in a few weeks
here where Tom's going to be not your
interm champ he's going to be your
straight up Champion your stre up
heavyweight champion Tom is the most
dangerous heavyweight on the planet
right now right now he is so John's out
a year and then you have Stipe who you
know he's all he's doing is waiting for
that fight apparently Stipe and Dana met
in New York and Dana asked him you know
are you gonna retire after the Jon Jones
fight what do you want to do and he goes
all I'm focus is on Jon Jones basically
saying all I want is John them
retiring so you're you're going to make
Tommy espanol wait he can't wait but
you're going to have him be your interm
champ and wait till steepe and John
fight which probably a year from
now and even then let's say steepe WIS
retires and John's talked about retiring
so what are we waiting for just give
Tommy asol the straight up Heavyweight
Championship belt and let those guys do
that Legacy fight and if they want to
fight Tommy great if not cool the
division keeps on keeping on but right
now it's in this weird hold it it it's
hard for people to figure out because
you have the the shadow of Jon Jones
looming over I don't if I'm John I do
what Yuri did and I say I'm not comp
beting for a year I'm re relinquishing
the title yeah give it up give it up
instead of holding up the division you
got to give it up you have to for Tom
Aspen so you're not going going to fight
the winner of John and St B they're out
at least a year you got a London card
coming up in if they do it how they
normally do it was that February March
probably March
so you sah
gone yes I could be up CH that's just me
they always do one in March you don't
have to bring it up I'm just double
cheing dude we've been doing this for a
hot second dude um You probably do it in
March and then you would have your
options are SRO Gan or Curtis
blades probably SRO Gan makes the most
sense but it just again so he beats San
same position same spot stays active but
you still got the Jon Jones stpe looming
over your head so how many people does
he have to take out before he becomes
straight up heavyweight champion he beat
siron all right Curtis blades is an
interesting one but there's not a lot
there man it's just held up it's just
held up you're just hang on of this
Legacy fight with Jon and stie it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense the
UFC is going to figure that out and I
would assume in the next few weeks maybe
in January we we find out that they just
give Tom the straightup championship Tom
became world champion over Ser Sergey
pavlovich off a one week camp and
knocked him out at his game how weird
was it when you know they were doing the
face off there inside the Octon they put
their hands on each other I was like oh
that's interesting they're both like
congrats man and then starches him
starches him Tommy's biggest asset he
he's just faster than everybody
including suron including Jon Jones
including Stipe he's just faster than
everybody in the world everybody in the
world I hate to tell you but I told you
he's going to be a world champion a hot
second ago I've been on Tommy Aspen's
nuts not just because he's English but
skill-wise he's the most well-rounded
heavyweight on the
planet yeah the the UFC heavyweight
division is interesting because your
your champ Francis left right and goes
on to beat Tyson fur in boxing but he's
in pfl so that's never happening Jon's
there we're supposed to get the John
Francis fight that's not happening
because Francis is in pfl and then
fighting boxing with Tyson fur and who
knows what next JN gets
hurt and then they make you know then
the stip B's there and then St B only
wants to fight John and then you got
your best heavyweight Tom Asal as your
inter champ justas as they say in French
but remember Ste even said like why
didn't they ask me to fight you know for
the title why did I think the UFC wanted
to put John and STP together more than
St wanted that but according to uh
reports Dana and Stipe met I that's
after but that that was right that was
before this fight I like hey what do you
want to do he's like I want to wait for
John well that's weird if I'm the UFC
I'm like cool we can do that but you and
JN are GNA fight for a belt then we
can't hold up the division for a year
that's what it's just strange man it's
so
strange because your best heavyweight
isn't your absolute
champ
yeah yeah it's all mixed up and then
let's say John holds on to his
heavyweight belt and fights steepe in I
don't know next
December so then you're getting Tom Asen
your interim champ you're getting Jon
Jones if you beat Stipe in
2025 look forward to
that you know and then hopefully Tom
aspel is undefeated till
then it's it's just a it's a weird
confusing thing it doesn't make a lot of
sense to me it's tough to stri Jon Jones
cuz he's the goat he's the greatest to
ever grace the Octagon he's the best of
the best he's the greatest of all time
barut it's tough to strip that guy with
remember when Yuri gave up the belt at
light heavy we like that makes sense he
only had three fights he didn't have the
body work Jon does it's tough to go up
to JN whether he likes it or not and go
give me that belt why I beat s Gan I
destroyed sah Gan and because I get hurt
you straight me to the Belt look at what
I've done for you guys
so I get the dilemma with the UFC it you
have to do you can't just leave this
where Tommy's you know doing his thing
over here beating all
these contenders and then John just
because of his legacy's over here and
just hangs on to the heavyweight belt it
just doesn't make a lot of
sense and again Sergey I'm sorry Stipe
and John can fight whether a belt or not
we're going to tune
in yeah obviously and they both said
they're going to retire so what are we
holding on
to you know it's very
strange and that goes to the main event
with Alx Pier Yi told you but what a
great face off too best face off of all
time it was so intense straight up two
Samurai Warriors dude two Savages
absolute Savages uh I thought Alex won
the first round especially with the leg
kicks that was an issue for yui and that
definitely controlled the chaos of yui
as well he had he landed some good
punches but overall I thought Alex did
did very well there and then in that
second round you know The Knockout
happened with Yi as far as the
stoppage Mark Gard I Goddard right
Goddard yeah Goddard he he's I think the
best ref that we have so you have to
take that into account second he's there
he's closer than anybody Yuri was kind
of out on the feet and then he was
completely out when he fell down so I
can see how he could see that and stop
it especially when a guys in Mount the
only thing that's going to happen is you
got this Savage and alexp in Mount and
the guy's out you just let them rain
down shots so I can see I didn't have an
issue with the stoppage Yi also said I
was out it was a good stoppage so if the
fighter says that there's no story here
there's no narrative early stoppage if
the guy inside the oon who's taking the
punishment goes I was out
y'all got to stop because he said he was
out all good so I didn't have an issue
with it CU it's such a a dominant
position for a guy to be out and lay
down and then the the guy who's issuing
the punishment is in Mount you're
talking about some real damage lived to
fight another day so I was okay with it
to the other extent of that it is a
world championship fight yes so you kind
of got to let it just to be sure let it
go a little longer just a tad long one
or two and might and then come in and do
the Herb Dean where you tackle the guy
and you know like what do you okay
there's like two friends that or two
ways of thinking like there's referees
that know these Fighters really well
right they know how they survive certain
things some some people don't With Yuri
he always he gets I think he got up
kicked last time got knocked out came
back and won the fight yeah so if you
know that about Yuri like why would you
stop it that early especially if it's a
title fight that that's that's only Cav
if this isn't a title fight it's
whatever but when when it's a world
championship fight
we we got to let it go just just a
little yeah a little at least see how he
responds because the issue is is Yuri
popped up did a somersault and popped up
now he didn't have his wits about him he
popped up and his legs were
Bambi we still we need to finish yeah
yeah that's what I think we need to
finish we need the Finish but uh Alex
Pierre I mean he's a a glory uh Hall of
Famer and then he's a UFC Hall of Famer
middleweight champion light heavyweight
champion look at the people that he's
fought he did so fast it's insane dude
yeah I thought his Homes at light
heavyweight I've always thought he was a
light heavyweight I think he's going to
dominate at light heavyweight he's going
do very well there he's going do better
there than he did at Mid middleweight
there's better matchups for him as well
it's not such a a heavy wrestling base
there um you know he's beat the
middleweight champion he's beat uh the
greatest middleweight champion in izy
he's beat the current champion
Strickland and then he just beat yeri
he's beat y
it's nuts dude it's absolutely nuts his
resume and what he's done in a short
amount of time is absolutely nuts in
regards to his call out so he gets on
the mic and they wanted him obviously
the UFC wants to set
up um homeboy next the the the champion
the current champion Jamal Hill next and
he was cagide in the camera zooming in
on him and Alex decided to use the time
to call out Izzy he here's where
everybody's getting it
twisted Alex had said in interviews
before I don't think Izzy is done I
don't think taking a lot of time off is
smart especially you know he's one of
the greatest to ever do it taking a lot
of time off isn't the answer he just
needs to get the fire again and and come
back what Alex is doing is what Izzy did
for Alex Alex wouldn't be in the
position he's in wouldn't have became
the person this first ballot Hall of
Famer this complete badass if he didn't
have Izzy as his North Star if he wasn't
chasing the Izzy ghost that's how he got
to where he's at Izzy lit a fire under
his ass this is Alex words he was
drinking and they saw what Izzy was
doing was like holy it motivated him to
get this fire to stop drinking and to
become a two Division World Champion he
was motivated by Izzy and Izzy was
leading the way he goes I beat that guy
in kickboxing why can't I do it in the
MMA
and so Izzy was his Northstar Izzy was
the blueprint of how to become this
superstar that he is him calling out
Izzy isn't a negative thing him calling
out Izzy is a favor to Izzy him calling
out Izzy his way of paying this forward
it's him paying it back to Izzy he knows
Izzy's in a rough time in his life in
his career and Iz he talking about
taking three years off he's coming off
that horrible strickling loss he knows
by him calling out Izzy lights the same
fire that he had when he was at Rock
Bottom this is a tribute to Izzy this is
a motivational thing to Izzy this isn't
a knock on Izzy now obviously Izzy's
going to Izzy and postes the you know
the Frozen thing and all that's what
they do and that's social media but
these two have a special bond these two
are connected for the rest of their
lives Alex calling out is he is his way
to say hey bud
what you did for me I'm going to do for
you that's all this is I thought it was
brilliant now does Izzy come back in a
few months and they'd make that fight no
that wasn't the point if you think
that's happening right away and that's
the next fight you're off all he's doing
and all he cared about this how much he
cares there is love between those two
the only reason he did it is to motivate
Izzy to get off his ass and get back in
the gym whether it's the next fight or
not down the road they're going to meet
the whole point of that was to get Izzy
to wake up and see how much of a badass
he is that's him tipping his hat going
Izzy come on bud you did it for me I'm
doing it for you him going come on buddy
let's go there's love there that is a
great story that is a love story I'm
telling you man when I saw that dude I
got emotional when I saw I'm like Oh my
God look at that look at that he's
paying it forward Izzy got him to where
he's at now he's going to do that for
Izzy
this is freaking beautiful man that's
what that is so people going oh my God
what a cheap shot but no no you're so
off you don't know ax Pier you don't
know Izzy their relationship goes hard
back back back back what what Izzy did
for Alex this is Alex payt it Ford it's
freaking beautiful man that's all that
is that's all that that's all it is
you're not going to get Izzy back in
January February that's not happening
he's fighting Jamal Hill Maybe next here
and here's where it's similar to the
heavyweight division that division is
also bottled up that division is bottled
up like a hemorrhoid dude it's it's just
it sucks you got to poke it back in the
anus dude you gotta get the contenders
you got poked the anus dude I've had
them they
suck they're awful they itch dude they
itch and they hurt mine was size of a
small grape whatever I had to put my
legs up like a baby and my wife pop it
in dude so anyway you get it man you
know nope s been adab um but what I was
saying is the division is held up
because Jamal Hill blew his Achilles
out now eron Rogers blew his Achilles
out Aaron Rogers has the access to the
best doctors to all the supplements he's
kind of walking but you know it's going
to be a hot second Jamal Hill doesn't
have the same access Jamal Hill is not
coming back anytime soon so you're not
getting
Alex versus Jamal Hill anytime soon so
what do you
do what the freak do you do you got raki
and Yan
fighting yep you got Johnny
Walker coming off that weird you
know that super weird
thing
um you could fast forward Johnny W
Johnny Walker Alex is such a fun fight
yeah and then you got you know you got
Anthony Smith at
eight and they they don't like each
other Anthony Smith is on the
broadcast but Jamal Hill and uh Alex
didn't happen anytime soon just not
happening any time again it's so weird
the division's so weird heavyweight so
weird magamama and kov beat it nerd we
can't have that wrestling in here
can't do Yan Alex again if Yan beats uh
racket it's going to be a
disaster You're Gonna Go Johnny Walker
Anthony
Smith yeah story with Anthony but then
the fun fight with Johnny so yeah the
most entertaining fights Johnny Walker
yeah that'd be my pick and I said that a
hot second ago you remember as well
that's the fight there's so many good
fights for Alex at light heavyweight so
much more exciting matchups so much more
pay-per-view MoneyWise and buys at light
heavyweight than middleweight all day
all
day so like I said the light heavyweight
and heavyweight division is Like A
Hemorrhoid it's all clogged
up what else you got Jen oh we got some
more ads if we can take a little quick
break let's go with fume fume oh I'm
glad you said this man fume this episode
of the shop Show Breaking Down usfc 295
and hemorrhoids is brought to you by
fume cold turkey may be great on
sandwiches but there's a better way to
break your habits we're not talking
about some weird mind voodoo from your
crazy neighbor or some weird Instagram
Guru nope we're talking about my sponsor
fume and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of some crazy
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit that's right
instead of vapor fume uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural it's intense flavor
so you're not going to miss stuff The
Vape daddy over here Casey we got him on
Fe man he's vaping all the freaking time
like a teenager I'm clean oh one week
one week thanks to fume thanks
fume Casey's clean all right you got to
try the all new fume baby start the
holidays off right with a good habit by
going to trif nume.com SL shab that's TR
t r y fume fm.com
and get in the journey pack today fume
is given you guys 20% off until December
1st when they use the code sha to help
make starting the good habit that much
easier start the goodh Habit atrium.com
Shob to save an additional 20% off the
journey pack today until December 1st
and 10% off for the rest of the year all
right that's fume trf nume.com
Shob awesome and we got got meter meter
the holidays are finally here we get to
stuff our freaking faces eat like
there's no tomorrow it's a holidays
don't be on a diet although I'm on a
diet whatever and Shop the best deals of
the Year oh my God the holidays are here
I know the coolest product to cook your
meals that also makes the perfect gift
dads love this dude I'm talking about
meter that's m e a t r meter it's a
really slick smart meat thermometer that
tracks the temperature of your meat and
you know when it's ready to come out of
the oven or the grill uh I use just a
feel Vibe I like to feel the thickness
of the steak but I would much prefer
this device with meter all right you can
press the whole family the app even
estimates how long your cook will take
and give you a countdown so you know how
long you have to kick back spend time
with your loved ones not worry about
that meat all right or make an
oldfashioned and you'll get an alert
when your food is ready to eat it's the
perfect way to use on any grill smoker
or oven I know a lot of you like air
frying and you can definitely do that
all right um this is the perfect tool
for your holiday cooking also makes the
perfect gift for someone who loves a
cook or a grill hey chane can I put my
meat on your grill this year on my grill
yeah that's it yeah dude let me put my
meat on grill dog set the time for yeah
hot shop meter that's me a.com for the
best kitchen tool out there and make
this season stressfree use it for your
holiday cooking or start shopping for
your Christmas gifts right now that's me
a t r.com all right meter perfect meat
my meat your grill
meter all right just one more and we oh
these are my favorite I'm talking about
sheath underwear sheath underwear makes
the most comfortable briefs I've ever
worn I got this your basic canes on
Daddy unies right now because my sheath
are all dirty because I've been rocking
them for week straight that's right dude
week straight and they don't stink they
feel comfortable they're the best
material ever it's this stretchy fabric
made out of moisture Wick and technology
so I can leave them on for multiple days
not going to lie to you guys all right
sheath is particularly useful for
staying cool if you're working out or in
a hot environment but also keeps you
warm comfortable and dry and cold
environments as well after try and
sheath you can never go back I got these
old undies on and it is driving me
bonkers all right I like the Dual pouch
keeps my man part separates only they
get all bunched up and start grappling
all right again this goes back to my
meat on your grill chin all right
they're the most comfortable cooking
grill yeah my meat on your grill J let
me put my meat on your grill temperature
100 sheath also has bamboo shirts
hoodies all designed for maximum Comfort
all you got to do is go to sheath
underwear. right now use the co promo
code shab that's S A get 20% off that's
sheath underwear. comom promo code shab
best undies
ever alrighty um so over the weekend as
well was uh that be not be is a game bre
fcck fighting yeah yeah
now my meat on your grill bless you and
then one of the guys you fought as as
well Ro Roy Nelson uh oh why you bring
up old [__] too I'm just saying people
thought that he won this fight too but
there's a split decision in Bel I
watched I watched like 75% of it and
what do you think Roy was on top
constantly controlling I know Roy kept
taking him down was landing on top uh
Allan was doing better on the feet but I
mean he Roy I think Roy should have won
for
sure 28 29 29 28
2928 it's a split so yeah it was very
close split I got to watch it again I
was watching on and off
um yeah tough fight tough fight to score
especially when it's bare knuckle and
when you're talking about Damage Done
Roy didn't do a lot with the grappling
either so it looked like the judges
really weren't giving them many points
there even though he's getting take down
in control beer knuckle MMA they want
damage yeah I get it okay so if you do
damage who do you think did more
damage I mean I don't know man it's
tough right it's a close fight all one's
more exciting I I'll say that much yep
yep yep and then Randy coost or Jason
Knight did you see that one ni I'll show
you the pict and shout out to Chase
Chase Sherman's he's he's doing well
yeah Chase Sherman's First Team all
violence with that bear knuckle
Randy Jason
Knight most violent minut you've ever
seen in Combat Sports tune in look at
his lip I know I feel so bad he always
gets so destroyed in these fights man
here here's what's about Jason Knight
phenomenal
Jiu-Jitsu ridiculous on the ground if
from The Ultimate Fighter like even with
Savvy vets or whenever they toss him
these young lines he would submit all of
them he's such a beast on the ground
just goes nah I'm GNA fight like the
redneck de Bros that's why they call him
hick Diaz look at his lip my goodness I
know it's but it got better look that's
after uh stitches and stuff looks way
better yeah he's such a
Savage again if you haven't seen it I'm
sure it's on social media it's um one
minute I think a minute and 20 seconds
of straight up violence in bare knuckle
that bare knuckle product that beer
knuckle MMA bro it is good it's good man
yeah it's a good concept ver knuckle MMA
it's good dude yeah I love it one of my
favorite things to
watch it's so good so this happened at
the postf fight press conference with uh
UFC 295 so this is from Bor China Depot
this is Dana White and just look at what
he
does fighter this com sparring
partner yeah I do not do not nothing no
so people are worried about
Dana his hand might just F fell
asleep so jacked there you go yeah I was
holding the mic so tight my hand fell
asleep I was just going to say he's so
jacked now and shout out to him when you
wear a suit so look look how tight that
suit is on his bicep there so it's
restricting the blood flow and he's and
it makes it even tighter when you're
like this right so his hand fell asleep
that's all that is it's just cuz his his
face was doing like like this as well so
that sucks he's like God damn now did it
look like he was having a stroke yeah it
did just I'm telling you i' I've been
there dude it's it's big bicep problems
in suits his hand fell asleep that's all
that is that's what I thought too dude
when him and dude talk about a squad
walking in these boys came in with that
you know storm the capital energy when
you had Tucker Carson little Donald
Trump
trump what dude I was at a uh it's like
a restaurant bar called beer garden as
soon as he saw a trump on Trump on
screen everyone started going did you
hear the crowd in in Ming Square Garden
the
crowd dude I'm telling you but yeah it
went nuts
nsos see Bill Burr's wife yeah flip him
off I didn't see that part yeah every
time they showed Bill Burr he was
yawning he
like yo who does he even like fights I
don't I'm sure he yeah he likes it but
you know he's also pretty tired he's
there for the New York Comedy Festival
oh yeah yeah he did that now his wife
they I saw online she either flip Donald
Trump off or she was just flipping the
camera off either way bad
luck and she's black too so that was my
girl like hey what are you
doing can't sell tickets to just the
woke we got sell left and right by
tickets baby all right all right so we
didn't get a chance to talk about this
on this show we talked about a little
bit on I think did we talk about fire no
we didn't no yeah we talk about all so
yeah the the announcements for 297 298
and 299 these are great fights that are
lined up here's my question for you guys
after I read this so Dana White
announced Monday you got Shan Strickland
defend his title against Rus dupes DDP
that's a great freaking fight then you
have and that's on in Toronto UFC 297
takes place January 20th sign me up then
you have UFC featherweight Champion
volkanovski returns at 145 PBS Elia
toira okay take my money it's a great
fight that's UFC 298 then you have sha
Ali versus Cheeto Vera and March on UFC
299 yeah here's my question between
Strickland DDP uh volkanovski toia and
sha suugaan Ali and Cheto Vera which
fight are you most excited for the last
one for me om Ali Cheeto yeah for me
they're all good man one a one B one c
yeah and I think I would say DDP
strickling for me that's exciting but
such a good fight but do you do you have
someone winning by a lot or
no I don't know what's gonna happen in
that fight okay what you you who do you
have winning by a lot Ras oh interesting
yeah you think DDP is just going to
steamroll Sugar I mean uh Sean really
not steamroll but like wow hot tap by CH
over here hot take let me put my meat on
your grill man it's hot over there take
dude let me put meat you had your grill
is hot daddy that's a hot take bro um
interesting with Sean Strickland's
defense you think DDP is gonna be able
to land I just do
yeah hot hot hot Grill chin over there
man interesting they're all great fights
yeah they're they're fun fights sugar
Cheetos
great is GNA I'm more curious about
Strickland and DDP than the rest of
them all of them are great I'm just
saying that Strickland d DP I'm like oof
I don't know what's going to happen is
strickman as good as we think he is is
he as good as or did is he just have an
off night and now we're now when you
look back you're like holy [__]
Strickland's really good or was it just
an off KN night for Izzy we're gonna
find out yeah and then DDP was set out
to for death you know him not taking the
iy fight but it's just who's available
during the time they wanted to
discipline DDP but they couldn't so I'm
rooting for DDP I love that I love that
as
well yeah great fights man phenomenal
fights um and I think Nick Davis our
producer for Golden hour he said that
the volkanovski AIA Tor fight will most
likely be in
La which would be cool yeah if you want
to go to it I don't know if we're doing
a fight campaign or not but yeah be a
good time to do a fight campaign
although UFC probably use most of the
fighters for the promo stuff but we'll
see it could be fun
yeah okay so I'll tell you what I I
wouldn't go to that um La fight I mean I
would go to any of them but I'm more
excited for that uh in the Vegas Sphere
for mexic Independence dude that's gonna
be sick he said well Dana say it's going
to be the biggest Combat Sports event
ever insane it seems like it might be
man yeah it's gonna be so dope yeah okay
so I guess during this this um this
weekend there was a few fighters on a
bus a UFC bus yeah there's a riot there
was yeah there's like a protest going on
I don't get too much into the protest
but what was the protest over Palestine
and all that yeah so but why were they
attacking the fighter because it's just
people that are in a bu cause chaos yeah
I think they're just in the way
protesters are so lucky those Fighters
were like say what we don't have a side
here but let's jump on out this bus put
our meat on your grill you feel me so
there's Jamal Hill for sure uh Cory
sandhagen your boy sanman and also uh
Robbie Lawler were on that bus right I
heard Robbie Lawler this you have this
here yeah Robbie's saying was saying
conserve your energy if these doors open
we're going to need every ounce of it
that was awesome but this was a better
quote how's he not in the movie 300 so
Rand R this morning asked him about this
he said if things escalated we weren't
the ones in danger they were they were
that's like the dopest quote yeah bro y
that is freaking the movie 300 that's a
if you're if you're on a bus and there's
Riders you want Robbie Lawler on that
bus of course dude they say just
conserve your energy just stay calm
those doors open we're gonna need it
yeah he's a real and then he just starts
dropping bombs on these protesters that
would been fantastic I know especially
if the protesters recognize who they
were they oh [__] they're done I doubt
they would recognize they like oh my God
these these random people on this tour
bus can
fight uh but apparently the UFC security
was really good and they were able to
you know oh yeah handle all stuff so
that's of the best all right so this is
a little bit silly but at least both
parties what uhuh you don't want you
don't want to entertain this I got to PE
so bad you want to cover this YP okay so
we're going have to take a break you C
you guys discuss I get to PE so bad all
right case we got this all right yeah I
didn't see dude yeah so uh Deontay
Wilder had like a weird interview with
someone that they asked like would you
fight Nate Diaz cuz Deontay wants to be
in MMA and then he's like yeah I fight
Nate and then Nate replied as well that
he would fight him as well but the
discrepancy in their pounds you know how
much they weigh is so crazy so this was
the original
video let me throw let me throw a name
out you name at you that I'm hearing
like this guy wants to fight boxers Nate
Diaz okay we got Nate Diaz would you be
down
to you be down to get the MMA cage with
with Nate be down to get in there with
Nate for sure you think you can take him
in the cage we going see only one way to
find out so Nate responded with that he
said let's get these contracts written
up ASAP uh real fight shizzel yeah right
uh respect to real fighter down to fight
for real all love the boxing this is
different real all that other stuff so
yeah that looks to me like a case of a
camera's in your face and you don't want
to look like a punk so you're like yeah
I'll fight yeah I'll fight him I'll
fight anybody I don't think a that would
actually happen and B I don't think
Deontay would do it
it would be like it'd be interesting
though right because Deontay is so big
and is not that I'd watch it I don't
think it's gonna happen it's never
happening again he might as well call
out Michael
Jackson it would be an MMA let's get
this contract written up ASAP real fight
[__] respect to real Fighters down to
fight for real all love to boxing but
this is different real [__] lfg
1993 not happening not ever no no
commission would ever sanction that I
mean so let me ask you this so if it's
an MMA though since
Nate okay he's way smaller right but he
knows MMA Deontay barely started like
bit because the weight difference and Oh
I thought because and and well a because
the the weight discrepancy there's that
which isn't going to get sanctioned then
also B they're not gonna allow Deontay
Wilder with zero fights to fight too I
thought that would balance itself out
there I mean no no no commission is
going to do that but Danel white even
said like that that's never happened
before he was kind of like not saying
that's so you know normally he'd be like
we're not doing that that kind of stuff
but if Nate and Deontay went to the UFC
to do some crazy fight it seems like
Dana White's like kind of
like I don't
know
well Al righty this one's pretty crazy
so Usman Naga made of who is khabib's
cousin he's suspended for six months
for something that he took that he was
supposed to get a Tue for right but he
didn't and people are thinking it's
steroids but his manager saying it's not
steroid steroids it's it's a
prescription medication it's not the
same thing as home girl on the UFC
roster that was busted came out it was
Aderall she had Aderall uh prescription
and didn't report it and that showed up
so his isn't EPO or HGH or steroids none
of that because they wouldn't give him a
six- Monon suspension it'd be two years
if it's some real [__] but the thing
that's weird is like why don't they say
what it is you know they just don't but
you know it's not anything major if it's
six months six months like okay yeah you
just didn't report it not a big deal if
it's two years he was taking that Gold's
Gym Venice Beach Deca winst straw this
is just some some weird oneoff six
months is nothing he' been out six
months anyway yeah I mean it just sucks
they strip him of his belt well they
should only strip you if it's certain
things they shouldn't strip you just if
you test hot for some random medication
you take every day and didn't report
it's stupid so it says here it's just uh
it was overturned I don't know if it's
stripped or not but it the the win over
Brent premise is overturned count yeah
which is stupid okay so anyway Conor
responded to this and I think all the
the Twitter the tweets are deleted now
but there's some screenshots of him here
and it gets kind of really like dark
crazy yeah I am not one bit surprised
upon hearing about another nurov team
testing positive steroids Hypocrites of
the highest order whoa and then steroids
are shame of Allah hangs over the Neta
Clan
cheaters khabib's dad oh is doing
tumbles in his grave I had to like
Google what Haram means it's like um
it's a for it means forbidden in Islamic
yeah yeah so that's
dark and then this picture I don't know
how legit this is but apparently this
is Islam back in the day jacked all them
boys are Jack all no they're all jacked
for sureck but the fact that Islam looks
like like that jacked is
like yeah yeah here's the problem so
they announced Connor and Chandler are
gonna find that UFC 300 is it 100%
though pretty sure so if that's UFC 300
are you gonna have Mev on there as well
and then you got always got to worry
about the makev crew Conor's crew like
the security oh yeah that CRA just the
Mayhem they hate each other dude this
ain't helping no dude the tumbles in his
grave thing that is so deep that's such
a deep cut that's I don't like it no
okay actually do you want to entertain
this or not
it's it's all about fans thinking
something so this is a conspiracy thing
about Yuri all right yeah I'm out there
they're saying uh Yuri Accused by crazy
fans of Faking injury and you saw it
cover up by conspiracy because they
looked at his way and stuff you know he
said he had like one of the worst
shoulder tears ever and there's no
surgery there's no there they couldn't
see scar scar marks on it stuff I was
looking for that as well there's no scar
marks I mean as far as the pictures that
we see I mean but I don't know how that
I don't know where do they start digging
into your shoulders when you do that
kind of surgery you know yeah did they
go into the armpit is there any of that
or this day and age they don't you're
not going to see the big huge slice like
it's the 9s there usually two little
dots they go in there but I see so many
lines here like it's yeah you could go
through anywhere yeah it was just like a
fun little conspiracy thing uh so Jake
Paul is this kind of a random he's going
to be fighting a an actual like real
boxer this time name Andre Andre August
not really that famous or anything but
that's going to be December 15th and he
is good record too yeah 10 and one so do
we think this guy's better than Tommy
Fury probably right I would imagine cuz
Tommy fur's opponents remember yeah they
were like the worst great this guy's
winning legit fights yeah but I mean
it's it's a weird thing I thought he
would fight more you know influencer
type people this is him it's it's
twofold here says it's a Jake want to be
taken serious as a boxer wants to
actually pursue boxing and go down the
path of legit boxing which I completely
disagree with but to each its own if
that's what he wants to do do that bud I
support you and this is on the right
track if if the point of his career is
to make money and get views and uh be a
prize fighter we're all prize Fighters
if the if if the goal of his career is
to just get the most eyeballs and most
money possible this ain't it dude keep
fighting the MMA fighters that already
have a fan base and aren't boxers mhm
this ain't it nobody's going to tune
into this no one is I mean it will never
it's not going to do anywhere near the
numbers I'm sure for sure but again
teach It tone he's like no I be taking
serious as a boxer I got to fight real
boxers even though you've never heard of
them I'm still going to go down that
path I don't like it I think you should
fight older MMA guys with huge fan bases
and keep knocking them out making all
the money but that's he might be set he
might be like I'm good man I actually
want to pursue boxing and this what he's
doing so this again more respect to Jak
PA I wouldn't do it I take easier fights
for more money instead of fighting the
no namers tough boxers cuz only gets
tougher from here you know yeah if that
guy which I assume he is better than
Tommy Fury he's probably G to lose this
one and I guess you go back to MMA
fighters but it doesn't make a whole lot
of sense to me for many many reasons but
again do you Jake I support him but
that's what makes him pretty cool though
man like to to want to fight actual real
boxers that's cool man it's cool I'll
tell you what's cool when I started
boxing online was the furthest thing
from my mind and then we started selling
fireing the kid merch that's right we
started selling fireing the kid merch me
and my brother were shipping it up sent
it to you guys and it was a beast but
then came along Shopify it's so easy
because of Shopify CH Ching all right
shopy is global Commerce platform that
helps you sell at every stage of your
business from to launch your online shop
stage to the first real life store stage
all the way to the did we just hit a
million ORD stage P Shopify is there to
help you grow and help you get there
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout up to 36% better
compared to other leading Commerce
platforms sell more with less effort
thanks to Shopify magic your iip powered
Allstar Shopify Powers 10% of all
e-commerce in the US all right plus
shopify's intensive extensive help
resources are there to support your
success every step of the way because
business that grow grow with Shopify
sign up for a $1 per month trial period
at shopify.com Shob all lowercase shop
all lowercase go to shopify.com Shob
lowercase now to grow your business no
matter what stage you're in shopify.com
Shob
chiy this episode of the shop show is
brought to you by the best crom on
planet Earth however you want your
creatum whether it's powder gummies
Taffy shots energy shots K dips all
right they got it all it's the One-Stop
shop for the best katom on the planet
we're talking about happy hippo kratom's
the wild west I only trust them I reach
out a happy hippo because I use the
product every single day standup
podcasting at the gym chilling on
Sundays I'm always on creatum it's happy
hippo.com prom code thick with three C's
23 for 30% off the entire website for
Life 20 20% I'm sorry I got overzealous
there 20% off it's freaking thick 23
happy hippo.com thick 23 for 20% off for
Life share that code with your friends
your mom your aunt whoever your Uber
driver y'all can all get 20% off by
going to happy hippo.com promo code is
th23 for the best katum to ever exist on
this weird weird round Planet we're on
called Earth it's happy hippo.com prom
code th23 get you
some uh we'll bypass this oh have you
seen the back and forth with uh chill
sunen and Jorge Mazon it got nasty yeah
but the way okay I'll just show you
chill's response so Jorge mazal was on
Errol helwani show and he was like man
all these guys are coming after you now
call him a Juice Head Right Juice Head
well I CH will explain it right here
just a quick clip from his uh Twitter
Instagram he says come see me you you
want your ass whooped come see me he
then came at me on Twitter either called
me a [__] or he called me a Juice head
and then says to me keep that same
energy when you you see me in person
does he think he's talking to somebody
else you're not going to come up and
look for trouble but if you come up to
me I'm not that guy there's nothing
about what you know about me that would
make you think that I'm that
guy and I'm thinking like dude
if I don't know I if cha and Jorge
fought I kind of feel like chill would
beat yeah I do at Cha's age have you
seen CH in his last Bell Tour fights
listen I love one of my favorite people
on earth now I don't know what ch's
contract is but what about J mozell
versus cha and beer knuckle MMA you
think CH would do that yeah take all my
money yeah dude I would take all my
money chill's a badass though that's why
I think they're both badasses of course
but yeah yeah but I'm with ch he's he's
not that guy who talks all his trash see
in person he's like Wella be cool yeah
I'm not sure I'm sure they you see Dylan
dannis and Bisby oh they were just
messing around oh is that just messing
around messing around and they actually
kind of hugged
yeah um yeah anyways CH did a bunch of
tweets we can't go through all of them
but there's just a ton of tweets about
uh Jorge and some are kind of funny I
think CH had some help writing jokes but
uh put Jorge if you want to scrap you
have to beat one of my students first
Kobe K oh scratch that but there's like
a million keep going but are you allowed
to kick with the leg that's wearing the
house arrest ankle monitor Maz I do want
some just trying to be clear on a few
regulatory matters is your corner going
to give you a prison Juice Box instead
of water then he put uh George yeah
George can you travel out of the state
without ear Marshall shacking you to
hand Dolly I like like Hannibal
Lecter no man bun am I the last person
you turned on or just the
lus how many of your text to me asking
for help because you're a dull unfunny
should I release is a dozen enough yeah
we'll just stop with he just keeps going
yeah
fight do Jorge's uh bear knuckle I'll
watch
that alrighty
[Music]
um oh that's Luke Thomas dude you
remember it was just a veterans veterans
day what on Saturday I think it was but
uh that's him as a Marine Way Back in
the
Day badass he looks [__] so different
gangster doesn't he yeah uh oh this I
thought was super cool of chill sun to
reply to uh Steamroller for vola but the
highest of highs lowest of lows that's
the fight game the chil put just comp be
professor at the Garden you had 15,000
fans that cared about you not the result
as you walk back to your hotel and you
pass the women on the street who has
mentally fast clutch in a cart with a
bond come thread what the low was you
brought honor to your team to your city
and protection to your country you think
we're gonna abandon you now yeah I'm
with ch's all the love and support for
Matt that's the game dude yeah um okay
so some of these are like cool posters
from the last fight that just happened
which is this is from I don't know how
9,000 Creations which is dope right NYC
gangsters God dang how gangster y look
there man I know super cool and then is
this the freaking picture that you
always talk about or is there another
one cuz I don't know what you're talking
about that's not it jeez it's close
though that's not it so every time we
talk about this people tag me they're
like this is the one this is one and
it's never the one I wonder where you
found it or saw it I that's close but
it's just not there yet um
um okay anyway tis
all um the fights
then so it's Brendan Allen Paul Craig at
the Apex it's very very edging us as you
say Chase Hooper Jordan uh Sweet and Low
yeah love it yeah he's one of my face
sugar in the tank love Yeah Yeah sugar
in the
tank yeah tough card yeah so that's
what's happening there uh there's also
actually a fairly big Bellator hell yeah
it's big you got AJ ver Sydney Outlaw uh
Pitbull
stot Danny yeah hell yeah Sergio Pettis
pachy
mix MAV versus Jason Jackson great card
ridiculous
card and that's pretty much it dude is
that it that's pretty much it all right
kids I am I'm at the ice house this
Thursday shabin friends got some great
friends coming along that's Ice House
8:00 p.m. one show only shoping friends
I mean some monsters at the Ice House
Pasadena and the keep on truck and tour
starts in Chicago December 8th and 9th
down in Nashville January 25th then
that's Nashville one night one show only
in Nashville on the 25th that's a
Thursday then that Friday January 26th
to 27th I'm in Austin Texas then I'm in
Edmonton uh I'm in Vancouver Plano Texas
come get your tickets at thick boo.com
uh new episode of Toontown which
features the first episode is my TRX
turn into a TRX demon Hellcat that is
debuting tomorrow on the freaking
Toontown YouTube new YouTube page go
comment like we're doing a bunch of dope
stuff on there so hope you guys enjoy it
is that it that's it all right kids love
you guys let me put my meat on your
grill I'm
out